it's a curious thought but only when you
see people looking and ridiculous
do you realize how much you love them
made you choose that one real quick Oh
porous moustache I'll forget your name
but never of things not yours anyway you
look absolutely yes do you think the
original holds up to an audience today I
haven't seen it yeah it's pretty
incredible guys have you both seen the
original I have not because I was told
by mr. Brannon aku I think I watch it
when I was younger because it celebrates
a timeless classic this kind of work can
be done more than once for sure the
greatest films the greatest novels every
now and then has to be remade very
reason is so that the next generations
will pay attention because they don't
always like to go back and revisit
things can I had a really good take on
it
it was the script that had a kind of
edge to it that I don't think the
original one had so it felt like making
a different man was rummaging around my
cabin in the middle of annoying tomorrow
you are certain it was a man I know what
it feels like to have a man in my bed
what goes into making a Hollywood murder
mystery
first things first would have to be the
cast I suppose and what a cast this is
we all realized that we were following
an enormous footsteps and that we can do
it and that we were capable so we didn't
try that's why you just see a lot of
laziness on the screen particularly from
I mean Leslie didn't even try to do a
Sean Connery impression day one he
walked in and he said Matt you know you
read one of Agatha Christie's famous
quotes of Sean Connery for me good
advice is always certainly to be ignored
that's no reason not to give it that's
fine so let us catch a killer
the real killer is right here one of you
people
[Music]
[Music]
you